-I wanted to try
something fun with you.
I thought that we could act out
a dramatic sports
locker room scene together.
-Okay.
I've always wanted to do this.
But first we have
to fill in the blanks.
It is time
for "Mad Lib Theater."
-Here we go.
-♪ Mad Lib Theater ♪
♪ Ah, ah, Oh, yeah ♪
-Alright.
So here's how this works.
I'm going to ask you
for some silly words,
nouns, verbs,
adjectives, etcetera.
And as we do that,
they're going to be written
on cue cards
right over there,
and then we're going to act out
a dramatic mad lib scene.
-Okay.
-Alright.
-I can do that.
-Alright. Ready for this?
We're going to start with this,
a type of Halloween candy.
-Twizzlers.
[ Mid-tempo band music plays ]
-Last name.
-Cumberbatch.
[ Laughter ]
-That is a good last name.
How a baby would say three.
-[ Irish accent ]
Tree.
[ Normal ] I don't know
why I went Irish.
I just went pure Irish.
-[ Irish accent ] Tree.
Oh, he's a little Irish baby.
-Tree, tree.
-He's a little Irish baby.
-Tree, he's a little Irish baby.
-Tree.
-Count is tree.
-[ Normal voice ]
An adjective.
-Succulent.
[ Laughter ]
-The succulent.
Plural noun.
-Bouncing melons.
[ Laughter ]
That's --
That's an adjective
and a noun.
You're welcome.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Bouncing melon.
-Yeah, I don't know, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Exclamation.
-Huzzah!
[ Laughter ]
-Ice cream flavor.
-[ As Michael Scott ]
Chocolate chip.
[ Laughter ]
Mint Chocolate chip.
-Mint Chocolate chip.
-Michael Scott.
-Plural kitchen appliances.
-Dishwashers.
[ Laughter ]
-Type of dance.
-Gangnam Style.
[ Laughter ]
Another adjective.
-Snarky.
-Type of profession.
-Dental hygienist.
-I love my dental hygienist.
-Yeah.
-They're the best.
-Clean those suckers.
-Worst gift
to get on Christmas.
-Grocery store coupons.
[ Laughter ]
They suck.
-Wow.
That's a really bad one.
I'll agree with that.
-Never got that.
-Another adjective.
-Bubblicious.
[ Laughter ]
No idea if that's a real word.
-Bubblicious is great.
Another word for big.
-Gargantuan.
[ Laughter ]
-Poor cue card guy.
-Yeah, he's like, "Screw it."
-He's like, "Gargantuan?"
Name for a cat.
-Mrs. Puddlesworth.
[ Laughter ]
It's like Mrs. Buttersworth.
Yeah. Yeah.
-It's about the same.
-Puddlesworth.
-Mrs. Puddlesworth.
-Yeah.
-What's a pet peeve?
-Oh, I absolutely
have a pet peeve.
Talking on speakerphone
in public?
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
Yeah, I kind of.
-Yeah, no, no, no.
-Come on.
-Get an earpiece.
-Get a grip. Alright.
-Yeah, get a grip, people. Yeah.
-A little self awareness.
-Talking speakerphone in public.
-Good.
-Write it out.
-Fast food slogan.
-[ Spanish accent ]
"Yo quiero Taco Bell."
[ Laughter and cheers ]
-You did that really good.
-[ Normal voice ] Thank you.
I ate a lot of it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Cartoon character.
-Oh, boy.
I have a lot of favorites.
Tommy Pickles.
Tommy Pickles. "Rugrats."
-Wow, from "Rugrats"?
-Yeah, a little rugrats.
I'm old, man.
-Wow. Tommy Pickles.
That's great.
-How to age yourself
in 30 seconds.
-Wow, "Rugrats."
No, that was great.
-Thank you.
Verb ending in -ing.
Dashing.
♪♪
Thing you'd find
at the beach.
-Metal detector.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
'80s sitcom actor.
Tony Danza.
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
-[ As Tony Danza ] Oh, way.
-Oh, way.
Angela.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Cereal mascot.
-Captain Crunch. Yeah.
Got to go with Captain Crunch.
Crush the roof of your mouth.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Chuckles ]
Yeah. Never get soggy.
-No.
Type of dinosaur.
-Brontosaurus.
-Nice Brontosaurus.
Thank you.
National monument.
-Grand Canyon...
I think. I don't know.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
What is a national monument?
Is it a building?
The White House.
-I think it's...
-Can you name one?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Mount Rushmore.
Mount Rushmore.
Mount Rushmore?
-Yes.
-Alright, alright.
You guys were like,
"Yeah, you're an idiot."
-No. Mount Rushmore.
-[ Mockingly ]
He played football. Ha ha ha.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, look at this guy.
Yeah, this guy wants --
This guy wants to host
"The Tonight Show,"
he doesn't even know
a national monument.
-You're going to go nuts
because I want another monument.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh...
I-I have no idea.
I don't know.
The Statue of Liberty.
-Yes.
Yeah. Okay. Okay.
Okay.
Yeah, Yeah. Thanks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks, guys.
-I'm not --
I'm not being --
I'm not making it up.
Another...
-This is ridiculous!
-One more.
Another monument.
-I dropped out of college
to play in the NFL.
-No, it's alright, just...
You want to just say
Grand Canyon?
Let's just say Grand Canyon.
-Yeah, I want the Grand Canyon.
-Because it's not,
but it makes me laugh.
-Yeah.
-I...
-Alright.
Best friends nickname
Growing up.
-Mine.
-Yes.
-Con dog.
-Con dog?
-Con dog, yeah.
His last name is Conley.
Evan Conley.
-Con dog. Shout out to --
-Shout out.
Shout out to Evan.
-Shout out to Evan Conley.
Con dog.
Famous movie, quote.
-"Stay Golden, Pony Boy."
-Oh, I love that one.
"Stay golden, Pony Boy."
Alright. We have all
of our answers right here.
We're writing them on cue cards.
Now let's perform the scene.
You ready?
Yeah. Let's go, buddy. Let's...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, you Twizzlers,
Listen up.
[ Laughter ]
It's half time
of the championship game
and Coach Cumberbatch
and I want to give
a little motivational speech
before the second half.
-[ Irish accent ]
Now we are down by tree,
and you guys are playing
like a succulent,
bouncing melon group out there.
Huzzah!
[ Laughter ]
So angry my mustache
is coming off.
-Hey-hey-hey, hang on,
hang on, hang on.
[ Irish accent ] We are the
University of
Mint chocolate chip.
Home of the fighting
dishwashers.
I wasn't Irish before,
but I am now.
We didn't --
-We drank a lot.
-But we drank a lot of those.
Benny.
-Yeah. They do it to you.
-We didn't come here
to embarrass ourselves.
We came here
to do Gangnam Style.
-Now, I know
that's other team.
I don't know how I got
Irish the whole time.
There's a bunch of snarky
dental hygienists out there,
but you've got something
that they don't.
You got grocery store coupons?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes. We're down.
Do you think all
You haven't been there?
When I was your age,
I was just like a lot of you.
I was bubblicious.
-Bubblicious?
[ Laughter ]
-I was gargantuan.
I got dumped by my girlfriend,
Mrs. Puddlesworth,
and I almost got
kicked off the team for talking
on speakerphone in public.
But you know what I did?
I woke up every morning
and I looked myself in a mirror
and I said...
"Yo quiero Taco Bell."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Football is a mental game.
Now I want you to imagine
that you are Tommy Pickles
and you are dashing
down the field.
-That's right.
-You catch that ball.
And you go towards that end zone
and you score that game
winning metal detector.
-Look You --
you want to go back out there
and see Tony Danza
looking back
at you with disappointment
in their eyes.
Or you want to be carried out
on everyone's shoulders
and everyone cheering
"It's Captain Crunch."
[ Laughter ]
Are you listening?
You -- You Brontosaurus.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-He's out.
-You got to take that hit.
-Yeah, that is...
His head...
-Hey.
-His head's facing
the other way.
-It's like the old days.
It's like the old days!
[ Laughter ]
Now let's remember the plays
we're about to run.
He's facing the wrong way.
No, his head inside the helmet.
-Alright, Take a nap.
Take a nap!
He's -- He's resting.
-The helmet didn't budge.
-It didn't work.
Look...
Let's go over the plays.
-We got Mount Rushmore.
-We got the Statue of Liberty.
-And, of course,
the National Monument --
The Grand Canyon.
-The Grand Canyon, of course.
Yeah. You know that play?
-Of course.
-Don't act like
you don't know the play.
-Everyone knows it.
-You all got that?
We need you to go out there
and win one for corn--
for Con dog.
-Corn--
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-We got to win one
for a Con dog.
Now let's bring it in
and huddle up, everyone.
And let's say the chant
we shout before every game.
-Stay Golden, Pony Boy.
Stay golden, Pony Boy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My thanks to J.J. Watt.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]